hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and today i will be
covering the insane developments
in the black clover manga everything
from crazy new
overpowered magic spells to noel finally
admitting that she likes
asta this chapter had love it had war
and everything in between so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the black clover
content on this channel you want to see
more you know what to do leave a quick
like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to anime opera or
maybe you watch our videos but you just
haven't subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram
at animeopror finally this video will of
course contain black clover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have
been warned the story picks up right
after hosta manages to prevent loro
bachika from literally exploding as a
result of megicula's curse
however asta confirms what i had
speculated about
in my previous video he was able to use
the demon destroyer sword to absorb
some of the curse and prevent the actual
explosion but he was not able to
completely eliminate the curse
curses from loro's body in my last black
clover video i mentioned that
if asa could just absorb the entire
curse in like two seconds using the
demon destroyer sword
then megikula's overpowered status would
quickly collapse
since the demon destroyer sword could be
the ultimate weapon against her
but after all of that build up for
megikula and her magic
that would be way too easy so i had a
feeling that asta's curse absorption
abilities
would be limited they had to be in order
to make things
more interesting for his part liba is
shocked to see that megikula
is here he refers to her as the supreme
devil
and he says that she definitely
shouldn't be here now since only the
first gate to the underworld has been
opened liben knows that makikula belongs
on a far
lower floor within the underworld
perhaps even the very lowest floor so
seeing her here so soon
understandably confuses him liebe also
makes it very clear to asta that without
their devil union mode they don't stand
a chance against megicula she is just
too
powerful but with that said makikula is
already impressed with hosta
he was able to negate a portion of her
curse even within
decaying world and so megicula can tell
right away that this must be the
legendary anti-magic human whom she has
been hearing so much about
from vanica megikula is fascinated by
the concept
of anti-magic but she's also working on
a tight schedule
so she declares that playtime is over
osta could prove to be a lot more
trouble than he's worth if makikula
doesn't take care of him right now
so she prepares to kill both vernica and
loro in order to manifest fully
into this world as soon as possible okay
hold on a minute
is megikula really saying that vanica
still isn't
dead after all that happened to her i
feel like most of us had just assumed
that vanica was already done for
since her body looked like it had been
wrecked beyond recognition
if vanakkah isn't even dead yet then we
honestly can't assume that anyone is
dead
and that includes gaia and this type of
stuff has been tabitha's mo
throughout the series so yeah unless
someone is directly confirmed to be dead
you can't assume that they're really
dead and in some cases like with julius
even direct confirmation of death
doesn't mean that the person is really
dead
just as megicula attempts to activate
the curses and end
vanica and loro's lives charlotte steps
back into the fray
and her magic succeeds in negating the
effects of megicula's curse
at least for the time being but megikula
doesn't understand how this is even
possible
charlotte was clearly defeated and she
was out of magic
and yet now she has somehow managed to
recover way sooner than expected
and her magic power is actually rising
that is when real steps in and explains
what's going on
earlier on when real used his twilight
of valhalla spell
we were under the impression that
makikula managed to suppress it
and render it useless but that is not
what really happened real reveals the
twilight of valhalla has a powerful
effect
but it took a while for this effect to
activate
namely while twilight valhalla is active
it increases the magic power of all of
rail's allies within a certain range
and if that wasn't enough no matter how
much damage real and his allies take
they will not die as long as they are
within range of twilight of walhalla
whoa that is such an insanely useful
spell to have in
any team battle and since black clover
is full of team battles
this is a huge development now twilight
of valhalla appears to only last a few
minutes
and once the spell disappears all the
damage that will received during the
time that it was active will return to
him
so there are definitely drawbacks and
there is a time limit but real is
willing to make that sacrifice
if it means defeating megicula rill also
explains that the spell had not taken
effect when asta showed up
so real was not able to save loro
himself and if asta didn't arrive
at that exact time laura would have
exploded and
everyone would have been killed
thankfully asta arrived and bought real
enough time to create
the ultimate magical painting twilight
of walhalla
mekikula is once again impressed and
fascinated by her human opponents
although to be fair she's probably
impressed because she started out
completely underestimating them
mkikula concludes that on their own
humans tend to be weak and insignificant
for a supreme devil like her
but when they work together and combine
the unique effects of their various
magic attributes
humans can become a truly formidable
force so
now we have a battle to the death within
the same narrow space
between decaying world and twilight of
walhalla
between megikul on the one side and asta
noel
charlotte and ryl on the other but just
when it looks like megicula might be
losing her advantage on the battlefield
she reveals yet another insane magical
ability
it turns out that vanica and megikula
created an entire
army of living corpses made of blood and
steel this army is made up of 100
magical zombies who emerge from the
ground
and begin attacking our heroes and these
zombies are not just like random weak
humans they are all former dark
disciples who were essentially
sacrificed for this
very purpose again i have to say that
makila's curse magic is so freaking
versatile and so useful
as long as you have enough prep time and
since this battle is taking place on
megicula and vanica's home turf
mekikula probably has a ton of tricks up
her sleeve
now the fact that these dark disciple
zombies are made of blood and steel made
me think of assier silva
vanika has blood magic so that checks
out
but is the steel magic a reference to
ossier
could this be a clue that one of the
dark disciple zombies
may turn out to be ossier herself i mean
probably not i assume that her body
would not be
here but if that were the case it would
be absolutely
horrifying for noel imagine noel having
to fight against her
own mother in zombie form after
everything that she has gone through
already man that would be so rough and i
definitely don't want to see noel
dealing with that although to be fair
this would lead to yet further
development of her character
and noelle's character development has
been a major theme
in these past few chapters moving on
even though asta is there
on the battlefield other than saving
loro from certain death
there isn't much that he can do to help
the rest of his friends defeat megicula
at least not for the time being because
he needs the devil union mode to be able
to make a real difference in battle
and as of right now he is still unable
to access this
transformation hosta needs more time
which means that noelle and the others
are going to have to
step up and that is exactly what
our girl noel does just the fact that
asta is now there beside her
gives noel strength and it inspires her
to keep on fighting
in fact it is in this moment that noel
finally admits to herself that she
really likes
osta i mean we've all known this for a
very long time
but internally noel has been trying to
run away from this fact up to this point
and yet now finally noel has come to
terms with her massive crush
on asta and that is a huge freaking deal
for all of us
astax noel shippers i mean for all of
you shippers because i am definitely not
a shipper you guys
seriously though noelle's character has
progressed so much
and she is now finally able to admit her
feelings for austin now of course
admitting them to herself is one thing
and that is important character
development
in and of itself but is noel going to
have the courage to actually publicly
confess her love
directly to us are we going to see
charlotte
and noel confessing their love to yami
and asta at the end of this
arc that would be kind of awesome when i
think about it and i can't wait to see
them all going on incredibly awkward
double dates and of course if yami ends
up with charlotte and asta ends up with
noel
that means that i get vanessa to myself
so everybody wins
anyway being the absolute chad last that
she is
noelle doesn't fixate too much on
romance because she knows that she is
on a battlefield once again noel vows to
take down mkikula
and she suddenly transforms into her
final
saint-stage form that is how this
insane chapter ends and man was this
ever hype i'm guessing that noel was
able to use saint stage again because
twilight of valhalla
allowed her to recover enough of her
magic to give it another go
which of course means that noel is back
in this
fight since this is a very personal
fight for noel
it makes sense that she is still taking
center stage
i assume that she still can't use spirit
dive for a while
so i'm thinking that we are about to see
noel using ultimate water magic
in the very near future without spirit
dive
ultimate water magic will be her most
powerful weapon against megicula
now tell me what did you guys think of
this chapter
personally i really enjoyed it although
there were both pros and cons
the big con for me was the fact that
vanica seems to still be alive
and if vanica ends up surviving this arc
and gaia also survives
then everyone is just going to assume
that fights in black clover don't really
have any stakes because no one
ever dies not even side characters on
the other hand
i loved seeing noelle's continued
character progression
and i'm just so impressed with her and
i'm really rooting for her
both in this fight and in her romantic
pursuit of asta
i also like the fact that asta's demon
destroyer sword isn't just some
overpowered silver bullet that can
negate
all of megicula's curses in an instant
this means that the fight against
megicula will indeed continue
and that it is going to be extremely
interesting so
is noel about to use ultimate water
magic
and is that going to be enough to defeat
mkikula or are we going to have to wait
for asta to get back into devil union
mode
also do you think that noel will
actually confess her feelings to asta
once this
epic battle is over finally do you
accept me shipping myself with vanessa
as
canon let me know down below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black lover content please leave a
like to let me know
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and of course while you're here
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed it's just how
youtube works
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he is
an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata pate
heffa
al-jatal hirokami water the toasted chi
the spike
emperor otaku spidey life chanel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist cody
hebert and monkey d
quilly finally thank you also to our pro
hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red-haired raven angel cruise ratheora
very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joanne garcia
techno ted fat boy games corey mcgowan
and soul ray slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you